china was the fifth nation in history to
become a nuclear power when it detonated
an atomic weapon in 1964. yet given the
fact that china hadn't fully
industrialized yet was internationally
isolated and its economy was on the
verge of collapse how did it manage to
do it how did china build a nuclear
weapons program so as of the 1950s china
had just finished a long and brutal
civil war which had been preceded by
world war ii the civil war had seen
mao's communists victorious with the
defeated chiang kai-shek's government
fleeing to taiwan when tensions between
the mainland and taiwan flared up in the
mid-50s the united states got involved
meaning mao was stuck to china's
leadership this meant that obtaining the
bomb was the best way to avoid a
humiliating repeat and fortunately mao
had a nuclear ally to the north the ussr
which was happy to help china require
nuclear weapons because china having
them had little effect on the ussr but
it sure did make the lives of america
and its allies in the region a lot
harder so off they went now the ussr had
tested its first weapon five years
earlier than this and so had a lot of
expertise by this point and the soviet
leader nikita khrushchev saw this
expertise as something that he could
leverage against china to keep it under
control you see khrushchev and the rest
of the soviet leadership were starting
to move away from that whole stalinism
bit of their history and given that mao
was a fan they saw a potential conflict
on the horizon and so what they did was
make sure that soviet scientists were in
control of the project and that without
them china wouldn't be able to complete
it which is why when mao denounced
khrushchev as a lame fake communist who
was too nice to the west the soviets
withdrew from the program taking both
know-how and important components with
them this left the chinese not knowing
how to proceed safely but mao wasn't
interested in safety mao was interested
in proceeding now it won't shock you to
know that trying to fumble your way
through building nuclear weapons using
what the soviets left behind and hoping
for the best was not a great plan and as
a result there were numerous setbacks
the death e turns out this stuff is kind
of dangerous style of setbacks
eventually the chinese government
accepted that you can't just demand that
science be achieved and it allowed the
program more space and within five years
of this the scientists involved had
cracked it and china was ready to test
its own bomb which it did in late 1964
much to the annoyance of the already
existing western nuclear powers who
previously only had to worry about the
soviets the americans were particularly
worried about another country building
massive amounts of weapons that they'd
have to match warhead for warhead but
the chinese opted to not go down that
route instead the chinese military
pushed for a strategy of making any
nuclear war with china cost too much
which is the strategy that china as the
world's fifth nuclear power still uses
to this day i hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
a special thanks to my patrons james
bissonette mr wolfe kelly moneymaker
skye chappelle jerry lamdin jordan
longley adam stalter corso wolf gareth
turner marvin castell why in hockey
captain cydog spencer lightfoot boogerly
wiggly matthew shipley maggie paxkowski
aaron the white robert wetzel marcus
asner anthony beckett alex schwinn the
muk whopper gustav swan coppertone
spinning three plates mo winston cayward
charles the first ben evanson and
scottish trekkie